رحل هازار وانتهى مشوار فني بدا في العام
للفنان السعودي فهد الحيان الذي وافته
المنيه اثر سكته قلبيه مسائل اثنين
كان مسلسل طاش ما طاش بدايه انطلاقته
لمشواره الفني وعرفه الجمهور من خلال عدد
من الشخصيات الكوميديه اشهرها ازار التي
احبها الصغير والكبير يبدا بعدها بحصد
نجوميه ويشارك في عدد من الاعمال وعلى
سبيل المثال للحصر خلك معي ابو العصافير
وهشتقه ومسلسل من ناوفينا
وفي العام 2006 انتج مسلسل غشمشم الذي حظي
فيه بدور البطوله وامتد لسته مواسم ابوي
راح اقول لامك تصلح قهوه
يلا ابوي يلا ابوي
كافي ولا تركيش وشو كافي ولا تركيش
مسيره فنيه حافله وسخت في ذاكره الجماهيره
بشخصيات متعدده اشهرها هازار ورويشد
وغشمشم ارتفعت بعد وفاته الدعوات وتزاحم
التعازي الوسط الفني في الوطن العربي كافه
لتعزيه ذوي الفنان فهد الحيان الذي ترك
ارثا فنيا خالدا في الاذهان لصباح العربيه
محمد خالد الرياض لمتابعه المزيد
من الوثائقيات وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات